Ron DeSantis he's not doing great
against Donald Trump according to the
latest poll numbers desantis's
announcement did not close the gap
between him and Trump trump still has a
34 point lead in the race
Trump's lead is down a little bit from a
43-point lead
but that constriction of the poll
numbers appears to have happened before
Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis is
presidential announcement
I think DeSantis is a great Governor I
think he's got a very strong message I
think he's obviously an extremely
intelligent competent guy he's one of
the most conservative presidential
candidates we've seen in my lifetime I'm
not disparaging him I'm just describing
a fact his announcement didn't work it
hasn't moved the needle the Delta
between him and Trump is just still so
massive